welcome back we are answering all of
your questions about Medicare the klas
channel 8 phone Bank is open now and we
are joined by Rachel Townsend a licensed
Medicare agent to tell us a little bit
about it welcome to the show Rachel
thank you thank you so much for giving
us this information it's so important
that we're educated about it tell us who
is eligible for Medicare
um well anybody who's 65 certain medical
conditions of someone has them such as
COPD diabetes ALS also known as Lou
Gehrig's Disease or end-stage renal
disease we hear a lot about how they
change from year to year the plans and
so why should someone who is already on
a Medicare Plan have their plan reviewed
because of all these changes absolutely
benefits and plans change year to year
so you want to make sure that the
benefits you have meet your current
medical conditions for sure what is
offered by Medicare Advantage plans
Medicare Advantage plans offer Parts a b
and d of Medicare and we also offer
extras such as gym membership Vision
Dental hearing aids Transportation a lot
of great benefits these are really good
benefits I I'm thinking a lot of people
may not know about so that's why it's so
important to call what's the number one
question you get asked about Medicare
basically what's new for the next year
so we're always happy to share that
information well we're really grateful
for your expertise and for all the
people that have questions make sure you
call now the eight phone Bank is open
the number is
702-650-1101 they'll be answering your
calls until 7 pm tonight we'll be right
back
[Music]